and when donald trump started running  he said two things that got my attention  the first thing he said was radical  islam and i'm like hell yeah we don't  hear con  well yeah politicians saying that where  his words doing  he was like hell yeah then he said  something like  putting america first and then i knew  right then that was a man for the job  see we didn't hell yeah brother a  a politician with the work ethics of a  farmer and he did one hell of a job  who do you think this guy is most racist  against  he's a fine and he's a decent man with a  decent family and he worked for  like for whatever reason i think deep  down he may hate jews the most  and he cares about you i don't know why  i get that feeling he's on the other  side as well